Prof: We're going to
look at XXVII,
XXVIII and XXIX today of
Paradise,
three cantos that,
really, I think,
Dante constructs together and
where Dante puts forth this
theory of creation and cosmology
which are not quite the same
thing.
A theory of Beatrice that's
explaining the shape of the
cosmos, it's very difficult in
these three cantos.
It's done in such a way that
they are two different things,
it would seem,
creation and a physical
description of the cosmos which
we call cosmology and they are
because Dante's dealing with two
forms of the universe,
a spiritual one and a physical
one.
Now we're going to show all of
this as we go over the three
cantos.
I would like to argue that in
effect they are not quite the
same thing but not really all
that distinct.
There is a very tedious line
separating the two of them.
Where are we first of all in
space?
We are somewhere in space,
Dante has gone past now,
the heaven of the fixed stars,
with the examination of the
three words,
the three terms,
the foundations of things that
we experience as trust,
or we experience as existential
hope,
or a love that if you combine
it is always--
implies always--not in Canto
XXVI but in possibilities of
betrayal,
uncertainty,
so it combines both faith and
hope in a very problematical
way.
Canto XXVII Dante continues
with--in the afterglow of the
fixed stars,
and the canto just to give you
an idea about what formally is
happening here,
the first part of the canto
really looks back formerly at
Canto XXVII of Inferno.
There is clearly a parallel
between the two cantos.
Here Dante--you remember what
he does, he meets St.
Peter actually who has been
examining him but now after the
examination of the three
theological virtues he goes on
in a prophetic denunciation,
he denounces the collusion
between his place,
he says "my place,"
it's the papacy,
the place instituted
by--because of him he's the
Peter,
he's the stone,
and his successors.
That's the way it says,
so the canto literally looks
backwards and a parallel with--
you may have a number of
parallels with Inferno
XIX where Dante meets,
you remember,
the popes who are turned upside
down and the flames--
the kind of--the parody of the
Pentecostal fires out on the
plants of their feet,
but this is more clearly a
reference to Canto XXVII of
Inferno,
where this is the very
beginning, this is--
there is a hymn Canto XXVII,
"Glory be to the Father,
the Son, etc.,"
and then lines 40 and following
we have this great attack,
"It was not our
meaning,"
line 45,
"that on the right hand of
our successors should sit one
part of Christ's people and the
other on the left;
nor that the keys which were
committed to me should become
the device on a standard for
warfare on the baptized;
nor that I should be the figure
on a seal for sold and lying
favours, for which I often
redden and flash with
fire."
This is the fire of prophecy
without a doubt,
but it's also,
retrospectively,
a reference to the attack
against Boniface,
who in Canto XXVII of
Inferno,
is shown as he is in colluding
with the Guido da Montefeltro.
You remember,
so there is a clear--it's a
clear symmetry between the two
cantos.
I will hasten to add that Canto
XXVII is also--
has a kind of chiastic
structure because at one point,
just to give you this is a
formal description of what's
happening here,
a little later after this
outburst by Peter,
Beatrice and the pilgrim move
onto the next heaven,
which is around line 75 and
following.
The next heaven is the
so-called crystalline heaven
which is still material.
He's at the boundary of the
material universe.
It's still material but it's
very, exactly crystal-like;
it's a very thin materiality,
almost but not quite spiritual.
It's also called the primum
mobile because it's here;
this is the technical term that
they give.
It's here, in this heaven,
that we have problems of
origins, the origin of time,
the origin of space.
Dante goes on giving
this--Beatrice goes on giving
this cosmological description of
the universe in material terms.
Here, to continue with the
formal,
the issue of form now,
at one point Beatrice says,
"wait look behind you so
that you can have an idea,
you can measure the enormous
distance you have traveled from
the Earth."
He's at the boundary of the
material cosmos.
You might say,
well he's at the edge of the
cosmos; he's going to fall off.
That was always one of the
objections about the idea of the
finiteness of the cosmos.
Believe it or not in the
seventeenth century they would
never really fall off because
the universe is a sphere,
so the only place he has to go
to is back,
there's no literally edge,
every point is the edge and
every point is in a continuous
spherical curve.
Anyway, from the point of view,
he's arriving there so she
says,
look back and what does he see,
and this is the line,
"From the time when I
had," this is XXVII,
line 75, "From the time
when I had looked before I saw
that I had moved through the
whole arc,"
that's the language of this
sphere,
an arc, circle,
an arc just gives you an idea
of sphericity,
"from the middle to the
end of the first clime,
so that I saw on the one hand,
beyond Cadiz,
the mad track of Ulysses."
He pinpoints that little place
where Ulysses trespassed the
boundaries of the world--
of the Euclidian space he
had--for which he has been
damned in Canto XXVI of
Inferno.
This is what we call a
chiasmus, in other words XXVI
and XXVII--we do see that XXVI
that are an allusion to Ulysses
and Adam.
We talked about these figures
and here in XXVII of
Hell,
there is Boniface and then in
Paradise XXVII there is
this,
and there is also a kind
of--this is Ulysses so there's a
sort of chiastic structure;
XXVII of Paradise refers
to really VI of Paradise
and refers also to XXVII of
Inferno and XXVI of
Inferno.
The question is,
why does Dante pinpoint once
again Ulysses?
He sees at the west the point
which Ulysses had trespassed and
he calls it the mad track,
"the mad track of
Ulysses."
Clearly, Ulysses is still part
of this fascination that--it
exerts an incredible fascination
on the imagination of the poet
and the pilgrim.
Am I like Ulysses or am I going
to be lost now like Ulysses,
but at the same time,
it's a way of hinting at how
much he has exceeded Ulysses'
adventure.
Ulysses only went past the
Pillars of Hercules;
he, Dante, is now at the outer
most boundary of the visible
physical universe,
so there's a way in which there
is a little bit of detachment
and yet a constant fascination.
We tried to explain why he is
so fascinated with Ulysses.
At the other end he also sees,
"and on the other nearly
to the shore where Europa made
herself a sweet burden,"
this is really the eastern part
of the known world,
Europe, the rape of Europe by
Jupiter so that we really have
an erotic transgression and an
intellectual transgression,
as if the two are now once
again are involved in this--
in Dante's vision as if he's
now coming to the point where
knowledge and desire really have
to coincide.
He's coming to the point where
the beautiful and the good are
one,
at the point where all of the
great countries and distinctions
that we have been pursuing all
along nearly have to go on
converging.
Let me continue with this idea.
This is--before I go on with
what happens in the canto.
Dante then moves into the
primum mobile,
which is the place where I
continue with this.
He goes on line 100,
they go into "the swiftest
part of heaven,"
that's the primum
mobile.
All motion begins from here.
Dante is moving from what would
seem to be an ethical--the
ethical scene,
the denunciation,
Peter's denunciation of the
abuses within the Church.
That's done in a prophetic tone
but also from a tone of ethical,
the ethical language.
He goes into the so-called
primum mobile which
actually is the heaven of
metaphysics.
I have been telling you about
the grammar,
rhetoric, music,
geometry, this is what we call
the heaven of metaphysics and
you know what that is,
right?
You understand what metaphysics
means?
Dante refers to it as they did
refer to it, Aristotle refers to
as the first philosophy.
They called it first because it
reigns--it rules supreme among
all the arts and all the
sciences.
It's the most important of the
It's the point of arrival of
all the sciences and it's called
first philosophy because it
explains also questions of
origins,
and you see the language of
origins here,
the origin of time,
the origin of space,
creation itself,
the beginning of the world,
causes, foundations,
these are the--
this is the great Rome that
metaphysics discusses.
Dante, the interesting thing is
that in the Middle Ages,
and Dante has to connect it
with physics.
Physics is as--metaphysics
really go hand in hand,
one tries to give the
explanation of the physical
world,
and metaphysics the
theoretical, general rules.
In fact, and this you
probably--I should mention this.
There are people who believe
that metaphysics was not a term
that really indicated anything
really different,
completely different from the
knowledge that physics provides.
They would say that
was--metaphysics was called
metaphysics because it--the book
was placed on the shelf a little
bit after the book on physics.
You see what I mean?
It was really more a way of
defining the place of the book
on the library so to speak,
probably, but it was known as
that,
but it's probably more of a
fiction than anything else.
The fact is that there is such
a science for Dante that deals
with causes, origins,
beginnings, time,
etc.
One of the things that here we
have it's that Dante--
that Beatrice starts describing
line 100,
"'The nature of the
universe,"
here she placed the
cosmologies,
"which holds the center
still and moves all else around
it,
begins here,'"
so this is already the
beginning,
literally the language of
beginnings.
Here begins motion.
Dante stands at the boundary of
the physical universe and now
she gives and explanation of
this.
She just said he's at the
boundary,
"And this heaven has no
other where,"
place,
"but the Divine Mind."
The real beginning,
the real universe is in God's
mind,
so he distinguishes two worlds,
the physical world we see and
the spiritual world,
which is in God's mind.
In a way, and just to make it
very simple, Dante is journeying
into the mind of God.
There is one man who had
written a text,
Bonaventure,
whom you have seen--whom you
have met before and he wrote
this book called The
Itinerary of The Mind into
God.
This is a way of trying to
explore, to enter,
mystically enter,
the mind of God.
Dante doesn't do it in a
mystical way.
He tries to understand what's
beyond the physical world.
To give a description of this
universe this is the term that
keeps reappearing in the next
three cantos.
"Light and love enclose it
in a circle,
as it does the others,
and of the girding He that
girds it is the soul
Intelligence."
This primum mobile,
it really is a kind of curve
that wraps up all the other
heavens.
We have seen--this is the ninth
heaven, all the other heavens
have been--are enwrapped within
it, but it's not only a
boundary;
Dante views it as also the
beginning, the threshold for the
spiritual universe.
It's both the boundary of the
physical world and it's always
also the--
so it goes like this,
this is the Earth,
and growing,
and then we come to the ninth
this becomes at the same time a
kind of convex and concave semi
circle.
I have, believe it or not,
a shape of what I think is
Dante's cosmos and here it is.
This is--I'm going to pass it
around.
This is a shell but it's
actually really made and found.
This would be the--pass it
around here and then I'll
explain--
they're all spirals really like
the--
since Dante thinks of the
cosmos as a book and we would
call it a cosmobook,
that's a neology that I coin
here, a kind of cosmobook.
The book in the shape of a
cosmos, it's really a parchment
rolled up within itself.
You know what parchments are in
medieval and classical ideas of
the production,
the material production of
books?
We have the ancient parchments
which are all rolled up
like--the term is around a stick
and then held together by a
ring, that's really the shape.
It's a sort of a production of
books that in the history of the
book is later replaced around
the fourth century A.D.
by the so called codex which we
have for instance even in the
Beinecke.
A codex has--it's made of
quartos, it's made of folios and
divided like a book today made
of--it would have quartos or
folios.
If you go and see the
Shakespeare's--
the folios of Shakespeare in
the Elizabethan Club,
for instance,
if they let you go in or you
belong there,
take a look and see what the
codex really is.
Dante seems to be combining the
two forms.
Anyway, you have an idea here
of what the shape that I'm
trying to describe to you is.
They are a kind of,
if you wish,
they are spirals,
one following the other,
and next to it there is going
to be a spiritual universe,
another universe which we'll
come to in a moment.
This is the first description
that she's giving.
The idea of the sphericity of
space,
that's one thing,
the space is spherical and has
as the primum mobile as a
boundary and now we have--
Beatrice goes on explaining,
"Its motion is not
determined by another's,"
this is line 112,
"but from it the rest have
their measures."
Everything begins here.
This is the physical beginning
of the universe which we
inhabit, "even as ten from
the half and the fifth."
In other words,
it's as sure as it is that two
plus five make ten and "how
time should have its roots in
that vessel and in the others
its leaves,
may not be plain to thee."
Even time begins here;
time is understood then by
Dante.
Do you see what the--there is a
kind of a tree growing from a
part, the part of eternity.
He does not understand time in
a linear way,
there was a beginning and an
end, and it's not the wheel of
time or the wheel of becoming.
You may have heard this,
have you heard this description
about the wheel of becoming in
which this is a platonic idea of
time,
where all things are contained?
Dante thinks of the tree,
of time as a tree,
the roots of which are in the
pot of eternity and the foliages
are in--
reach us--reach into our own
world.
We are in the shadow of the
tree of time.
We only see leaves that will
fall because this idea of the
dispersion and the falling of
time,
the passing of time,
so this is the definition of
what happens in XXVII.
She continues after a while
with this--
about once again the language
of covetousness and moral
language about what happens in
the world and we move on to
Canto XXVIII.
Let me tell you I have not
forgotten that we ought to talk
about Ulysses in a little while.
Now it continues with,
XXVIII deals with the angelic
hierarchy.
We are now still in the
primum mobile but Dante
starts seeing into the other
universe, the spiritual
universe.
He sees a universe which is
adjacent to the physical
universe with--inhabited by
angels.
The corresponding part that you
have the nine planets,
the seven planets plus the
fixed stars and the crystalline
heaven,
and now you have the nine
orders of angels,
and Beatrice will go on
describing the three triads of
angels;
angels, archangels,
thrones, this is the language
that comes from the Bible,
the Old Testament comes from
Babylonian,
apparently in Persian sources,
apocalyptic sources and would
not seem to be really terribly
different from that tradition.
Here, we have also another;
this whole description of the
angelic order continues,
line 12 let me just focus on
this a bit,
"And when I turned again
and mine were met by what
appears in that revolving sphere
to one that looks intently on
its circling,
I saw a point," distance,
so we are at the boundary of
the universe;
another universe emerges into
view and Dante only sees "a
point which radiated a light so
keen that the eye in which it
burns must close for its
piercing power."
Once again, a series of
revolving spheres,
this universe is not the
projection of the other
universe;
they are separate and adjacent.
They are two hemispheres and
this is what happens in Canto
XXVIII and we go to Canto XXIX,
and I ask you to see how the
whole argument continues.
Beatrice has been explaining
breathlessly the whole question
of angelic hierarchy,
and by the end of Canto XXVIII
he sees--
she even mentions that the
order--actually it's Dante here
who mentions that the order--
his ordering of angels,
the hierarchy,
is very different from the one
of the pseudo Dionysius,
line 130 where he says,
"These orders all gaze
above and so prevail below that
all are drawn and all draw to
God.
And Dionysius set himself with
such zeal to contemplate,"
this is the pseudo Dionysius
who had written about the
angelic hierarchy,
and Dante goes on to say that
he differs from him,
that he just--his idea of
angels is a little different
from his and Pope Gregory's.
A statement of his own
intellectual independence,
both in terms of the theologian
and in terms of an
ecclesiastical authority.
And then Beatrice finishes the
description of this hierarchy,
meaning the sacred order,
that's what the Greek word
means,
the sacred order of angelic
intelligences.
Their function is to impart
motion to the spheres;
their function is to move
between the divinity and human
beings,
they are the messengers,
they keep the spiritual
entities and they keep moving
between God and human beings and
then we go to Canto XXIX where
now the language of cosmology,
about the order of the cosmos
becomes creation,
and I want to show this to you.
However, this shift to the
language of creation is
conducted in an extraordinarily
interesting way.
Dante wants to say that
Beatrice has been talking
nonstop about--
with probably a touch of
playfulness about the angelic
orders,
and then she moves almost like,
without catching her breath,
talking about creation,
Canto XXIX.
But look how this shift from
the order of angels to the order
of creation is described.
This is the beginning of Canto
XXIX,
"When the two children of
Latona,
covered by the Ram and by the
Scales,
both at once make a belt of the
horizon,
as long as from the moment when
the zenith holds them balanced
till the one and the other,
changing hemispheres,
are unbalanced from that
girdle,
for so long,
have face illumined with a
smile,
Beatrice kept silence,
looking fixedly at the point
that had overcome me."
What an extraordinary image.
Let's read it again so we make
sure that we understand it
because I'm not sure that it's
very clear,
though I think it's--I can make
it clear but let's look at this
again.
"When the two children of
Latona,"
meaning the Sun and the Moon,
that's really what he's saying.
He has to describe the fact
that Beatrice seems not to have
kept quiet that she went
endlessly from one thing to
another,
that's what I call the
playfulness of Dante's thinking.
He's saying that there was,
this is the image that he uses,
is when the children of Latona,
Apollo and Diana,
you know that,
the Sun and the Moon.
We're in the universe
of--though Dante is using
mythical language,
look at the language first of
all.
The two children of Latona,
myth;
"Covered by the Ram and
the Scales,"
science,
"Both at once make a belt
of the horizon,"
an Arabic word meaning the
boundary of the heavens,
so science, scientific language.
"As long as from that
moment when the zenith,"
scientific language.
The mixture and balancing of
science and myth,
but also a way of talking about
the--
a balance that is as vanishing
and as fleeting as it could ever
be, that's the point.
That there was silence but he
could almost not even tell that
there was a break in Beatrice's
speech.
This is what he is saying,
when the two children of
Latona,
the Sun or Apollo and the Moon,
Diana,
along the horizon,
they seem to be aligned
together and they are held
together by the zenith.
This is the zenith,
the highest point as opposed to
the nadir, right?
This is the balance that he's
describing.
They are kept in a balance
here, in a rare equilibrium,
when they appear,
seemed to be aligned together
and that balance and equilibrium
is quickly disappearing.
What is he saying?
He's saying that she almost
didn't stop speaking and then
she began, then she goes on with
the theory of creation.
"I tell,
not ask, what you wouldst hear;
for I have seen it there where
every ubi and every
quando is centred,"
place,
I have seen at a point where
space, and time coincide.
"Not to gain any good for
Himself,
which cannot be,
but that His splendour,
shining back,
might say,"
I stay,
"Subsisto--in His
eternity,
beyond time,
beyond every other bound,
as it pleased Him,
the Eternal Love revealed
Himself in new loves."
I have to correct my good
friend, dear old friend
Sinclair, because actually Dante
does not say that.
He says that love,
the eternal love,
actually the language which he
uses I don't know--
I hope your other
translations--those of you who
use other translations are
luckier,
"opened itself in new
loves," opened itself.
I take this to be a sexual
language as it can be found,
a new love engendered,
opened itself into new loves.
Then it in fact continues,
"Nor, before,
did He lie as it were inert;
for until God's moving upon
these waters there was no
'before' or 'after.'"
Before God's creation the
language is biblical,
from Genesis,
there was no before or nor
after.
In the physics,
this is an allusion to
Aristotle's physics,
where Aristotle has to define
time;
he says it's the measure,
we speak of time when there is
a before and an after,
because this is really what
time is.
The measure of motion in regard
to a before and an after;
Dante says that before this
time of creation there was no
such thing.
It could not be distinguished
before in terms of time,
there was no such a thing as
before and after,
and then he goes on just to
continue with this sexual
metaphor,
"Form and matter,
united and separate,
came into being that had no
defect,
like three arrows from a
three-stringed bow."
The question of creation as a
coming together of form and
matter is here described as a
conjunction.
It's the language of creation
takes place as an act of love,
that's the first thing
Beatrice's saying.
Creation comes through as
passion, a love passion,
it's an opening up in--love
opening up in new loves.
It's as physical,
the language of creation,
as it could ever be in terms of
the natural, the language of
natural production and
reproduction.
This is the context of what she
is saying, before and after.
It is as if to have a creation,
creation is that which
introduces the possibility of
distinguishing between a before
and an after,
introduces a difference,
that's what the language of
Beatrice is.
Let me go back to the image
with which we started.
Dante is wondering whether or
not there was any break in
Beatrice's speech.
He says if there was a break,
it was so fleeting as happens
with whenever the Sun and the
Moon along the line of the
horizon are going to be--
are aligned together and this
is if they are balanced and are
held together by the zenith
above.
That is such a fleeting moment
in the alignment of the stars.
Why this metaphor?
Not only he's saying that but I
think there is also an allusion
to Francesca here in Canto V.
Did you catch it?
Where he says,
"for so long her face
illumined with a smile,
Beatrice kept silence,"
she just kept on talking,
"looking fixedly at the
point that had overcome
me."
The point that had overcome me
is clearly an allusion to--not
only a point was that that
overcame us, Francesca says in
Canto V.
That's all, so there's an
illusion to Francesca.
The question that I have to
answer that I raised with you is
why is Dante mentioning these
two infernal figures and framing
his discussion on cosmology of
creation,
first of all by talking about
Ulysses and now talking about,
or alluding to,
not even mentioning,
but alluding to Francesca.
Why this one who wants to
transgress and trespass the
boundaries of the world in order
to know,
the other one who transgresses
the norms of what is allowed
because of love.
Knowledge and love somehow come
into play but they are in the
Inferno version.
What is he saying though with
this image?
Why has he talked about
Francesca, the Sun and the Moon
align briefly,
what do you think he's saying?
It's not a rhetorical question;
let me just--why do you think
he would use this kind of
language?
Immediately,
after Beatrice goes on
explaining the creation of the
world and the distinction
between a before and an after.
Why this metaphor?
Why this long paragraph?
This image here, anybody?
I think that Dante's asking
right here,
is it possible to localize a
break and he's saying it is as
when we speak that things seem
to be continuous and just as in
every syllable between a sound
and another there is always an
interval so there was in the
language of Beatrice,
and that's what to him is the
idea of creation.
It seems to be--there is--the
opposite of creation would be
the eternity of the world,
something which would be the
universe is eternal;
it has no beginning and no
identifiable break.
How can you tell?
If the universe is eternal you
have no differences inside it.
Dante wants to say it seems to
be a continuous--the universe
seems to have a continuous
extension.
Without time a kind of
eternity, it goes on and on,
and yet it's as when we speak
that you can identify the break,
there was however minute there
was a break between Beatrice's
exposition about the angelic
orders and now the exposition
that she goes into about the--
about creation.
Why then, the other two
metaphors, now it's time to
answer that question,
why talking through Ulysses and
Francesca?
Why evoke those two images?
I wish we could--I have to keep
that hanging awhile so it can
become a little bit more
compelling what I'm going to
tell you.
With it order,
"And as a ray
shines,"
Beatrice is continuing with
form and matter,
united and separate,
this is conjoined and pure,
pure and conjoined.
She says, "as a ray shines
into glass or amber or crystal
so that from its coming to its
completeness there is no
interval,
so the threefold creation
flashed into being from its Lord
all at once without distinction
in its beginning.
With it, order was created and
ordained for the spirits,
and these were the summit of
the universe in whom was
produced pure act;
pure potency,"
and so on."
The idea is that there is a
universe of creation,
the universe of creation which
seems to be very much like the
physical world,
it's described in physical
terms, the terms of the Moon and
sexuality,
the cosmological language and
scientific terms,
and yet there is some kind of
difference that is introduced.
Without creation we would not
have differences,
we would not even have origins
that is the language.
Now, why those two figures?
Why Ulysses and Francesca?
Ulysses, I think that what
Dante is doing,
finally is allowing us to see
what the world of Inferno
has to be seen as.
The world of Inferno
that we only saw as a world of
rejected,
as a world of evil and horror,
all of a sudden is now
retrieved as the best exemplar
of what we may come to know of
the spiritual world.
It is almost an imaginative
redemption that Dante goes into
about the actual idea of hell.
He's implying,
and that could become in many
ways heretical,
but I hope to show you that it
is not,
that the universe as it goes
back--as one goes back to the
beginnings,
clearly the journey to the
beginnings has to be seen as
redemption of order has been
falling away.
Let me just say it in a
slightly less tortuous way.
There can be no redemption
unless it implies that the whole
of evil is overcome and
destroyed,
so that even the world of hell
now appears all of a sudden as
part of what we get to know
about the ultimate structure of
the universe.
This seems to me to be the real
lesson,
the underlying and powerful
message that Dante is sending
through these three cantos in
the heaven of metaphysics.
Let me stop here before I move
into the next canto,
Canto XXX and see if there
are--let me take the questions
now before we go on to the next
canto.
I could go back maybe and try
to redo what I have been saying
because it's--
but let me see if there are
some questions and then we can
do that,
please.
Student:  Are you
suggesting
>
of the entire world creation is
redeemable including those
>?
Prof: He never says that.
Let me be very, very clear.
He never says it anywhere.
There is never an indication
thematically,
there is everything else that I
have said I could find
counterparts in a thematic,
thematized, in the sense that
it becomes part of a conscious
articulation on the part of her;
he knows and he thematizes,
he makes it a theme clear,
he never says that.
But there are two implications
though that I'm drawing on in
order to be able to make that
kind of statement.
The first is the very idea of
the cosmos as a sphere,
and the idea of the cosmos as a
sphere,
it really means that wherever
you are going and you are going
toward God,
then you are going back to the
beginning,
everything else can go back to
the beginning because that's the
form,
the shape of the cosmos.
I'm drawing out the implication
about this understanding of the
universe.
The other reason is that there
is such a thing as a redemption
and Dante's--
we didn't read the canto,
Canto VII of Paradise is
focused on redemption,
a new beginning,
that's what redemption means.
Redemption means that the
cosmos can go back to its
beginning and be restored in its
original form.
If this is true,
it could very well be that from
the point of view of the poem,
Lucifer is always going to be
stuck in his ice forever.
There's no hint that he can
move even.
Francesca is always moving
around in vicious circles,
remembering and then lost in
the labyrinth of time.
To her, she literally moves in
time;
memory--cannot think about the
past without being moved by it
and must move constantly around
it.
Ulysses gets lost who knows
where,
there is nowhere for him,
he has no sense of a place,
even from this point of view I
can go on understanding that in
a canto where a place matters,
Ulysses never had a sense of
belonging anywhere,
that's the utter dislocation
and a kind of--
he doesn't have a family that
holds him back,
the children,
the kingdom,
Ithaca, anything,
he just goes on moving.
That is the overt sense of the
poem,
but there is this theology of
redemption,
and I'm wondering whether
theology of redemption does not
entail necessarily that there is
a return to the beginning.
Before I go on though with
restatements of this--
I want to ask you to--because I
think it's one of the--
a technique that Dante uses
which is really extraordinary,
can you go to the beginning of
canto--
the famous image of Latona when
the two children of Latona--
beginning of Canto XXIX,
I really would like to ask you
to look at the Italian a little
bit.
I'm not going to read it,
I'm not going to ask you to
read, I'm only going to ask you
to look, I won't read it though.
At the first word,
quando right?
You all see that,
and look at line--
that's really the proem,
what we call rhetorically the
prosthesis of the canto,
the beginning of the canto,
the introduction of the canto.
Go to line 12,
the last word,
quando.
Go to the first--back to the
first line, the last word in
that line, Latona.
He says, "of Latona."
The first two letters
"la"
go back to canto--
to line 12, the first two
letters "la,"
draw this--
that's a chiasmus,
draw the lines together,
and they will meet exactly at
the word hemisphere,
emisfero,
that's the center.
That's the--hemisphere means
that they are--it's
half--hemi--the Greek is
the two half spheres,
the universe is two half
spheres composing one.
I think Dante's placing us at a
cosmic crossroads.
He is locating us,
he's telling us where we are
first of all,
but he's also telling us that
this universe has a kind of very
occult and very secret laws.
The poem has these secret laws
that regulate it.
I'm really arguing then that
there is this subtext that is if
a radical redemptive theology
would only entail the absolute
purification of evil,
so that the universe will have
to really go back to this kind
of Pythagorean purity,
but without the phases and
descents.
These are--you know what I mean
all of you, this Pythagorean
idea that the life of the
universe stretches for 360,000
years.
Did you ever hear about that?
360,000 years which are really
like the days of the year,
the 365 I think we have;
360,000 years.
Every 360,000 years the
universe rotates and goes back
to its point of origin and then
it--
decadence starts again,
the age of gold,
the age of silver,
the age of iron,
the age of paper we would call
it now.
It goes back to its origin,
that's not the way Dante
understands the movement of the
cosmos,
but he does understand the--he
does present this redemptive
event that makes the universe
return to its pristine purity,
that's why I made that
statement.
Any other points before I go
back because I really think I
should say all of what I said
before.
Any other questions so I can
help clarify these various
points?
Yes.
Student:  What is the
redemptive event?
Prof: I'm sorry.
Student:  What is the
redemptive event?
Prof: The incarnation.
The incarnation is the
redemptive event that allows--it
means what is the redemptive
event?
The incarnation,
I call it redemptive event that
would make the--
a new creation,
a new Adam has come into the
world and that new Adam,
through the sacrifice,
his sacrifice through the gift
God gave--
allowed the incarnation because
human beings on their own would
not be capable.
That's the theology of
redemption.
Human beings on their own would
not be able to save and redeem
themselves so that an
intervention from God,
through his son,
was made inevitable in order to
reconstruct and in order to
bring out and produce that
original order of the cosmos.
If that is true,
and it is true,
and you only have to look at
everywhere in the poem,
but Canto VII of
Paradise,
that's really where it is an
annunciation of this whole
theory in the terms of--
for those of you who are,
Anselm, etc.,
then that implies that there
must be some kind of general
remaking of the world.
That's what I think the
idea--but nonetheless this
should not obscure the fact that
there is a kind of a paired
juxtaposition between the
physical description of the
world and the spiritual
description of the world.
There are two hemispheres and
yet they are connected;
the spiritual,
the creation,
the experience of creation is
really the way of positing a
distinctionary difference into
the universe--
into the theory that the world
is eternal.
They are two conceptions that,
operative in the Middle Ages,
and they are really represented
by--
one is by Aquinas who is a
theologian but he is also a
philosopher,
and in fact,
he could be called as the
writer who wants to make a
philosophical theology.
He argues, he's known for the
famous Suma;
he wrote a track called Suma
Against the Gentiles,
not the Suma of Theology
but Summa Contra Gentiles
where he argues that the
eternity of the world,
the theory of the eternity of
the world,
that is to say there is no
creation,
he says could be
philosophically demonstrated.
It could also be
philosophically repudiated.
Philosophy can argue one side
of it, and he goes on arguing
that there is no way of thinking
of--the usual questions,
who created the Creator?
That kind of--the oldest,
these objections.
However, there is a view of
creation which is allowed and
it's possible on account of
faith,
but it also allows for the
thought of freedom,
origins, beginnings, etc.
Bonaventure picks up some of
these ideas, the ideas debated
in Paris in the thirteenth
century around 1270 in Paris.
Both of them are teachers at
the university.
Bonaventure says no,
this is untenable,
the idea of the eternity of the
world.
It is absolutely untenable,
because if the world were
eternal then we really would
have no way of--
no real succession of
generations, there would be
endless people who have been
living before us,
there's no evidence for this,
it would be endless forms of--
he holds, and he upholds the
idea of creation.
Dante intervenes into this
debate and says,
that it is effectively the
physical world and the spiritual
world are really one continuous,
they're one complimentary to
the other,
and yet there is a difference
between them,
and the difference between them
is the difference that he can
find in Beatrice's speech,
that little point of time,
that little intrusion of time
that distinguishes between one
sound and another sound.
The spiritual universe
originates in the world of
nature as a natural production
and reproduction,
all of God's love and the
physical world in exactly the
same way.
There is a kind of symmetry.
This is not Plato's inverted
universe.
The physical world is not
Plato's inverted world,
it's adjacent to it.
It is as if Dante discovers
that there are more dimensions
to the world that we see than
what medieval cosmologists,
or classical cosmologists had
imagined.
Interestingly enough,
and I don't say this is a proof
for any of what I have said at
all,
but there's a famous
nineteenth-century mathematician
by the name of Riemann,
a German mathematician.
I don't know how many of you
studied history of science,
he was--he's known among other
things for having been the
mathematics professor of
Einstein.
Well he went on with a team of
his students studying these
cantos of the Divine
Comedy to find evidence that
in fact Dante had already a
theory of fourth dimension,
that there is the universe that
we see and then there is another
universe.
It is almost as if the folds of
books,
the folds of the parchments are
exactly giving an idea--
that's Riemann's,
not me, an idea about what the
actual structure of the universe
may be.
Having said this,
don't forget to turn back to me
my shell, the emblem of what I
take very good--thank you.
Let me see if there are some
questions because I--we can go
on now talking about some of
these issues.
Please.
Student:  I'm still not
quite clear as to how in
reference to Ulysses and
Francesca in these cantos relate
Beatrice's description of the
universe and redemption back to
Inferno and how the
redemption of the universe
necessarily implicates including
Inferno as well as--
Prof: Excellent question
and I really welcome your
skepticism.
The question is about how
exactly do the figures of
Ulysses and Francesca shed light
on what's happening here?
Is it really tenable that
Dante's implying that
those--that the sinners are
going to be redeemed,
saved?
More or less that's--
Student:  Yeah and why?
Why they're brought up--how
they fit into that explanation?
Prof: Good,
I figure that's a crucial
issue.
It's interesting that Dante
should look at Ulysses and bring
up the image of Ulysses in Canto
XXVII.
I find it interesting in
that--and Dante,
one can say,
Dante is really unlike Ulysses.
Now he probably realizes how
different he is from Ulysses
because Ulysses went to--
he's implying how risky his own
enterprise may be which we have
seen before.
Ulysses was brought up in this
journey in canto--
with the meeting with the dream
of a siren was--
happened even before indirectly
many of the--
in some other cases XXVI,
in Canto I of Inferno
even,
and maybe we could just stop
there and say well,
Dante's still--that's a kind of
retrospective fascination.
He's looking back and
pinpointing that tragic moment
because--
he calls it the mad track of
Ulysses,
the madness implies that
he--this man had violated the
limits,
own limits, including the
limits of reason in his rational
pursuit,
philosophical investigation of
the world,
the scientific--he wants to go
into the--
unpeopled world to have
experience,
that's the key word for him and
yet that madness implies that he
had been delirious,
had been going off the track.
Dante maybe that too,
but maybe not,
maybe I'm really a little safer
now,
I'm in the hands of Beatrice,
she's guiding me,
a way of trusting Beatrice so
we could say that that is all
true and therefore I could even
see an element of relief on the
part of Dante,
we would even catch that.
The relief is that his own
adventure diminishes the epic,
the Greek epic hero,
he really did very little,
he just went beyond the Pillars
of Hercules.
That's all, we could stop there.
It happens though,
retrospectively,
we can see the story of Ulysses
as also the story of a
metaphysician.
Dante is in the heaven of
metaphysics, in what way is he
in the place of--what does
metaphysics deal with?
It deals with place,
deals with time,
and then we can understand why
Ulysses in Canto XXVI,
he seems to be going from place
to place is the metaphor that
distinguishes Ulysses.
Then Dante says,
he's a failed metaphysician,
but we understand that he
really was going to the
absolute,
he really was trying to go
where I'm going and there is
nothing else.
We stop there.
We go to Beatrice,
Dante meets--is talking to--
is listening to Beatrice in
Canto XXIX and he's trying to
figure out if it's possible to
think of a beginning.
How do things--you have the
eternity of forms and you have
the eternity of matter,
it's very difficult to know how
you could really distinguish
anything that was before from
what goes after,
there is no such a thing as a
before and an after.
He tries to localize time,
that's really the problem.
To localize time he says that
he really--Beatrice looked and
reminded him of the point--there
was a point of joy that overcame
him.
Maybe he's alluding,
because the language is that of
Francesca, so why Francesca?
Let me just explain it at one
point, maybe he's alluding to a
kiss the two of them--that he
remembers.
It's sort of very spiritualized
the context;
Dante's never vulgar,
maybe he's just alluding to a
kiss they had been exchanging,
or maybe the will,
the desire, the longing to have
a kiss now,
exchange a kiss with her.
One thing is clear,
that he's thinking of Francesca
as also a kind of metaphysician
because that's what we are.
What is the metaphysics of
Francesca?
Metaphysics of desire,
first of all,
a desire that--what does it
mean the metaphysics of desire?
Desire by its own definition is
metaphysical in the sense that
it's always moving beyond the
objects it gains because it
burns up the various objects.
Today I want this book,
then I want another book,
and then I want the car,
and then I want the library,
etc., that's the infinite
movement of desire which is what
we call metaphysics of desire,
so she's a metaphysician.
Not only she's as
metaphysician,
she lives in time,
so she's a complimentary figure
to Ulysses.
Ulysses is, you remember,
is >
Cauta, I left behind me Seville
and then I, etc.,
etc.
Now, Francesca instead says how
difficult it is to remember the
joys of the past.
I remember I was reading,
that day I began reading,
that day I stopped reading,
only a point was that that
overcame at that point of time,
a point of the book, etc.
Maybe Dante's really saying she
too is another failed
metaphysician.
They would like to be where I
am now, both Francesca and
Ulysses, so we are bringing them
to the place where Dante is.
Now, they are looking for the
same thing he is having now,
a conjunction of time and
eternity,
space and time,
ubi and quando,
to see the point where all
things cohere.
That's exactly where he is
looking.
How do I make things cohere?
Of course it's possible to
think--one way of thinking of
Paradise and the joy of
the blessed is to go on thinking
that my joy--
suppose that I were saved,
a very unlikely proposition.
My joy, it's possible to argue,
is increased by--
it's sadistic,
the view of those who are
suffering,
mercifully, I am saying that to
me it's the most improbable form
of beatitude but it's likely
that seeing someone downtrodden
and punished right like that,
could be that Dante is saying,
how lucky I am that I'm neither
like Ulysses nor like really
Francesca.
I don't think that that's Dante
though.
He's talking about cosmology
and creation,
the order of everything,
how this order is an order of
love and now he's coming to know
this order of love,
because now knowledge is love
and love is knowledge.
I think that by the allusion to
them he's also saying that here
on earth you can grant me that,
that's what I said before,
and I think that I'm not
pushing it to the point of
unbelievability.
The whole argument becomes
unbelievable,
I can stay here and say,
well now--what he's really
saying is that I am here and I
see how things go here,
but I know that sinful people
on Earth,
those of us who live in the
shadows of time,
this tree and we're under the
leaves of time,
then I know that in a sinful
way they were trying to do and
know what I now have come to do
and know.
I could stop here and say well
we're all happy,
there's no argument,
I think that that makes logical
sense.
I can push it to the point of
absurdity,
to say look maybe if this is
true, he's also saying not only
that they in a shadowy way,
in a dim way,
were anticipating the real
happiness in the sinful modes,
the sinners,
but that maybe they too if you
move out of this text--
as you know this is not said in
the text that they too will be--
are going to be taken and
placed into the bosom of Abraham
where all the blessed dwell.
Maybe too this is--is it my
wishful thinking?
I grant you,
it's probably wishful thinking
but I do have the theology of
redemption behind me that stands
as uttered by Dante in Canto VII
of Paradise.
I restated the whole thing in
two minutes, that's not bad.
Thank you.
Other questions before we go
back to--please.
Student:  Can you
comment on the presence of
Francesca, also in light of this
sexual language that comes out?
Prof: Yes,
can I comment about Francesca
in the fact that there is--the
creation is given in sexual
terms.
That this is love that opens
itself--opens itself to new
loves and so on.
I cannot help but play a little
bit of an etymological game too,
by the way, because this is the
world of origins and I don't
want to lose you.
I know there is only one class
but I don't want to lose you.
Of course the only--the way in
which Dante's conveying all
these senses is by playing with
the etymologies,
because etymology is the
science of the origin of words,
so let me give you only one.
I corrected my good friend
Sinclair,
inseparable from me,
I mean, I'm never going to
betray him,
but I have to correct him
because he says
"revealed,"
that's what he means.
The eternal love revealed
itself a new love.
He is missing the whole sexual
language which is exactly the
reason, thank you.
That's exactly the reason why I
think that Francesca too can
arguably be saved,
that's exactly the reason.
The term he uses is
aperse,
from the Italian,
in Italian we call it
aprire,
very close to in English we
have the word April,
by the way, as an opening of
spring.
Just to give you a sense of
etymology,
it comes from aperire
Latin which really means to
generate,
to bring to light,
as a woman brings a birth to
light and life.
That's really the word,
that's the meaning of the word,
so it's as sexual and as
productive as it can be.
Before I go back though to your
question about how is Dante
going to--
what Dante is saying is that
creation is the sexual process,
the sexual experience,
which is exactly what Francesca
also did,
breaking the law undoubtedly.
She is in hell,
is she going to be in hell?
Are we going to understand that
there is a possible continuity
between what she did in a
physical sense and what Dante is
doing in a spiritual sense?
This is the whole point of the
discussion on cosmology and
creation.
That there is some kind of
continuity between the two
modes;
not quite the same thing;
of course, creation is a
different order of experience.
There is a very thin line,
it's like a little breath
of--breath that Francesca can
release at sea--or Beatrice who
goes on talking endlessly.
She too, that's the difference
between the two,
so between the language of
sexuality,
of physicality in
Inferno,
and the language of
spirituality here in
Paradise,
the line that is continuing
between them and there is a
little difference but there is
also a possibility of a
continuity,
that's really exactly the
argument that I would make about
that.
Let me though tell you more,
in a historical way,
so that if you don't agree with
what I said so be it,
don't worry.
I don't agree with it
completely on my own but I think
that this--that's a radical
reading of the notion of
cosmology and creation in Dante.
Let me tell you something else
historically.
Where is Dante taking these
ideas from?
Whenever you read commentaries
on Dante,
and I hope that some of you
will go on reading and reading
also scholars,
thank you, critics--I see that
nodding is just--
my heart it just gladdens when
I see that.
They all tell you--and I
indicated that too that Dante is
some kind of an Aristotelian and
I was talking about metaphysics,
how Aristotle calls it first
philosophy,
Aristotelian terms.
They never tell you where the
actual sources of Dante are.
The sources of Dante about
cosmology and cosmography are
really neo-platonic.
The idea of creation,
especially one text that I have
to mention,
this guy who writes the
Cosmographia called a
twelfth-century man Bernard
Sylvester,
a Frenchman,
Bernard Sylvester who writes
Cosmographia,
twelfth century known as the
author of School of Chartres.
By the way this text were
available to Dante,
we have a text of this man,
Cosmographia,
one copy only because a
Florentine,
later--he had it in Florence,
by the name of Boccaccio,
some of you know very well,
he copied it down and
transmitted to us.
We know his handwriting because
we have his texts so we know,
this is 1340,
Dante of course wrote about
1302,
but clearly that text was
available then.
In this text,
Bernard gives an idea of
creation and cosmological ideas,
physical ideas.
They had been reading the
Timaeus in France and
they were always surprised and
wondering what is the
difference,
how can we go on having Plato
say one thing about creation and
Genesis saying something else?
How are we going to connect
these two forms,
these two sources of tradition
and authority?
They argue, he goes on talking
about the idea of a pre-existing
world of matter.
The natural world and a
malignant materiality and how
this malignant materiality is
subdued into shape,
and the subduing into shape is
always sexual language.
Matura is that which
produces,
generates, this is the text
that I believe stands behind
Dante's physical explanation of
a universe which is physical,
but at the same time it is not
just physical.
It is also a theory of creation
and it's the theory of creation
that has unpredictable
possibilities.
This tells you that things can
be renewed.
If you stay within the
bound--you see how he criticizes
the physical conception of the
world.
If you stay within those
boundaries you can't expect
anything other than what you
already have.
You cannot expect anymore evil
or any less evil than what you
already experience.
The only idea,
the way in which human beings
can think about renewal,
can think about change or
freedom, or origins is only
within the context of creation.
That's exactly Dante's argument
and that's the profound
justification for the
distinction between one order of
experience and a different order
of experience.
But if this is true,
and it is true for Dante,
then I have to take also
seriously this idea of--
this central event of
redemption, which now we
understand what he takes that to
mean: the moment,
the experience of the
incarnation.
This is exactly--it follows--if
he has to--
if he believes that there is
such a thing as--
and he does--creation then he
has to believe that there is
also the idea of recreation,
a second creation because the
first creation clearly didn't
work out all that well so there
is this other possibility.
Please.
Student:  I have the
sense that in these lines at the
beginning of XXIX that we've
been talking about,
that Dante is very aware of
being on theological thin ice or
skating close to the danger
line,
but the idea is the divine love
spills over out into a created
world so that it can be
reflected back,
endured, and loved in return in
the way that Paolo and Francesca
loved each other.
That's not far from the thought
that before creation God has
everything but is still a little
lonely and that suggests a kind
of imperfection,
or at least incompleteness,
but how can God be incomplete?
Dante begins this passage by
saying, not to acquire new
goodness for himself;
this is the
>
translation, which cannot be.
Prof: That's perfect.
Student:  That he wants
to announce before he offers his
neo-platonic vision of the
relationship of--that God had to
creation.
He wants to signal his
orthodoxy to doubters who might
hear in this something which is
less than perfectly Christian
because it comes close to the
idea of a needy God or a God who
in the way that every lover
needs something,
and other to love in return,
is in a predicament and
creation is the solution to the
predicament that God is in
before the world was made.
Prof: Okay,
the question is that--well,
the question is more of a
comment by the maestro here.
The comment is that Dante at
the beginning of Canto XXIX
seems to be on a theologically
risky,
on thin ice,
I am quoting,
because the notion of a God
who--
that Dante is really trying to
save his skin,
as it were, by claiming a kind
of theological orthodoxy when he
actually knows that the very
notion of creation whereby God
opens up into new loves,
it seems to imply that before
creation God was a lonely guy
looking for a partner,
some kind of Adam,
Adam in the garden replaces all
that.
That's really the question.
I think that's a very
interesting idea,
of course, but I have to--I
will respond not entirely in a
funny way, but I hope it will
come out as funny.
It's really the question that
St.
Augustine asks in the
Confessions.
There are always those people
who wonder, because that's
really what the question is,
what did God do before
creation?
St.
Augustine responds:
he was busy preparing hell to
people like you who ask these
kinds of questions,
and think--that's it.
The more seriously idea is that
indeed creation implies,
I mean that's a response that I
would offer,
creation implies a beginning
but this creation has been going
on forever and that the idea of
the Trinitarian God is really a
response to this problem you
have.
You obviously are,
I think, it's not obvious but
you--
to me it's not obvious I think
that you are appealing to a
different theological paradigm
of where the unity of God can be
the loneliness of God.
The Christian reading of that
unity is that there is always a
productive, an internal life of
love that always goes on
producing itself.
On that note of theological
grandeur, I thank you and I say
thank you, we'll see you.
Have a good Thanksgiving.